MARTIN GORNER: Hello,
and welcome back
on "Root Access Berlin."
We are again, recording
here from the Factory
Studio in Berlin.
And today, I have with me Jerome
Mouton, the CTO of SnapEngage.
Hello, Jerome.
JEROME MOUTON: Hello, Martin.
MARTIN GORNER: Can you
please introduce yourself?
JEROME MOUTON: Yes, absolutely.
So I'm Jerome Mouton, the CTO
and co-founder of SnapEngage.
We are a small company
providing software
as a service on the
Google Cloud Platform.
Our customers are
using SnapEngage
to engage their visitors
on their website
and to assist them
through a sales cycle
or for customer service.
MARTIN GORNER: So
let's see a demo.
Let's see what this looks like.
Here, we have the website
of one of your customers.
And I have opened
this little live chat.
We just--
JEROME MOUTON: Mm-hm.
MARTIN GORNER: That one
is provided by SnapEngage.
JEROME MOUTON: Exactly.
So these customers added the
SnapEngage JavaScript client
on their website.
And when you click on the
little button to open the chat,
this window popped up and
provide you the option
to leave a message or to
chat with this customer.
MARTIN GORNER: And
so today, we are
going to answer a question
that is a recurring
question on App Engine.
How much does this cost?
Every time I talk
about App Engine
with someone, that's a question
that comes again because it's
not so easy to determine
how much you are going
to pay for your application.
In App Engine,
everything is metered,
and you pay according to your
bandwidth usage, CPU usage,
and so on.
However, here,
with SnapEngage, we
have an application that
has a significant traffic.
JEROME MOUTON: Mm-hm.
MARTIN GORNER: And
so Jerome is going
to tell us about the associated
costs and how to optimize them.
So first of all,
Jerome, how much traffic
are we talking about?
JEROME MOUTON: On
a month on average,
we serve a few
billions of queries
in App Engine for SnapEngage.
And we use a fair amount
of instances at a time.
We have a few
dozens of instances
running for serving our queries.
MARTIN GORNER: All right,
that's significant.
And so can you tell us
what a typical query
landing on your
application looks like,
so that we understand
what's going on?
JEROME MOUTON: Yes,
so you are seeing
there's this chat window.
And to do this display,
we have to figure out
are someone in the company
able to answer the chat?
Is the user there to chat?
So the typical on PC, we do
on every customer web page
like this one is to first bring
in things App Engine memory
context the
configuration of the chat
team-- so lot of
confidential details,
including what is agent's
list for this team?
What are the different
tiers of agent?
what are in the rules
for assigning agents?
Once we have that, we
need to bring, also
in memory, what's the
status of each agent.
Are they online,
closed, offline?
How many chat does
each of them--
is really handling,
so that we know
how to best prioritize and route
the chat to the right person.
MARTIN GORNER: So you
have first a batch
of requests to the DataStore.
JEROME MOUTON: Mm-hm.
MARTIN GORNER: Sometimes
backed by memcache so as
to optimize them to get
the status of your agents.
And then you run a CPU
intensive computing algorithm
that comes up with the best
agent to answer this query.
JEROME MOUTON: Exactly, yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's see how
your cost breakdown looks like.
And indeed, it
seems that the CPU
is the most expensive part
of your App Engine cost.
So what are you doing to
keep that under control?
JEROME MOUTON: So
the first thing
that come in mind, of course,
is to optimize your code.
And if you run algorithms
which are inefficient,
you're going to use
more CPU for that.
Something else you
should do, if your team
has the skills on
different language,
is you should pick a language
that is also efficient on time.
Typically, if you go with
an interpreted language,
it will take more
resources at one time
than if you take a
compile language.
MARTIN GORNER: And so what
language are you using?
JEROME MOUTON: We're
using Java, which
I think your reader knows it.
It's a compile combine code.
So it's not exactly running
on the CPU [INAUDIBLE]
[? procedures ?] machines as
a [? generally ?] [? am ?]
between.
But it's very efficient.
MARTIN GORNER: So
it's certainly more
efficient than an interpreted
language like Python.
But you have another option
on App Engine, which is Go.
JEROME MOUTON: Mm-hm.
MARTIN GORNER: Which
is completely compiled.
So with that, probably, you
would get almost an order
of, well, almost a factor of two
of CPU saving compared to Java.
But you haven't tried Go.
JEROME MOUTON: We haven't.
But I think you should.
We-- that will be for the most
important services, something
we should do.
Let me just interject
something here.
Now, with App Engine
supporting modules,
in theory, we should
be able to have
some part of the application
using the send [? to test ?]
or send memcache that's
running a different language.
That's something we're
planning to experiment
using in the future.
MARTIN GORNER: So,
indeed, modules
have been introduced recently.
And so they allow you to
split your application
into different modules.
But those modules have their
own version, their own language.
However, it's still
the same application.
So they hit the same DataStore.
So that is a good idea,
actually, to experiment
with one separate functionality
written in a different language
and to see what the impact
of that on the CPU cost is.
JEROME MOUTON: Something
else I would like to mention
is like most cloud
platforms, you
can pre-reserve some
number of instances
that you're going
to use this week.
So once your application,
which level of usage
which is getting
more than basic,
you can kind of look
at what is the history
for the past few
weeks, decide that you
know you're going to use at
least that many instances,
and tell the App Engine
table that I want
to reserve that many instances.
You don't have to schedule
them over time, just saying
for this week, I will
use at least this level.
What you gain is
instead of paying,
I think, $0.08 per
hour, you're going
pay $0.05 per hour for
these reserved instances.
Which is a significant saving.
MARTIN GORNER: OK, so
it's almost half price.
JEROME MOUTON: Yes, mm.
MARTIN GORNER: All right,
let's go back to the list.
So the second most expensive
item here are DataStore reads.
Again, can you tell us
what you can do with that?
JEROME MOUTON: Yes, so
reading to DataStore
is expensive and also is not the
fastest operation you can do.
So App Engine provide the
platform memcache service,
which memcache, it's
just a key value pair
in the memory on one system.
So for free on the platform,
you get shared memcache service,
which let you put in
there some cached content
that you know you're going
to reuse quite a bit.
MARTIN GORNER: But it's a cache.
JEROME MOUTON: It's a cache.
MARTIN GORNER: So
at any point it
can tell you that it has
forgotten the content.
And you still must have it
somewhere in the DataStore.
JEROME MOUTON: That's
a true [INAUDIBLE].
But your code should
be smart enough
that if you don't find
the value in memcache,
it will then hit the DataStore.
But your hit ratio in
memcache should be sufficient
for you to send it maybe one
of a third or more requests
on the DataStore.
MARTIN GORNER: The
typical difference
between hitting the DataStore
and hitting the DataStore
through memcache is a reduction
of cost of a factor of 10.
JEROME MOUTON: 10 is just a
number I'm mentioning here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARTIN GORNER: But
it's significant.
JEROME MOUTON: It's
significant, yes, yeah.
Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: And so
this shared memcache
has some capacity.
It can handle some load.
And when do you know that
you are exceeding that?
JEROME MOUTON: So
yeah, shared memcache,
there's no real numbers
that we can kind of see.
We have about 100
megabytes of storage there.
It's shared across several
apps on the same app server.
What happens, though, if some of
your neighbors on the same app
server are using
a lot of memcache,
you could see some constraint.
Your memcache lifetime
may be reduced.
So when you see your cache hit
rate being reduced compared
to your usual, it's
most likely because you
are kind of hitting the
limit on the shared memcache.
MARTIN GORNER: So the
shared memcache is free.
It's normal that
it has some limits.
What can you do to
use more memcache
if that's what your
application needs?
JEROME MOUTON: Yeah, so
application like SnapEngage
having quite heavy
traffic, we are
making good use of what Google
calls a dedicated memcache.
So instead of having about
100 megabytes of storage,
you rent instances
of 1 gigabyte.
And I think the
instance is rated
for up to 10,000
operations per second.
MARTIN GORNER: So that's
quite significant.
A gigabyte of data and
10,000 operations per second,
you can handle a lot
of load with that.
JEROME MOUTON:
Definitely, and you
can get several of these
1 gigabyte instances
if you need to get more,
more operation per second.
So it's not something typical
for small starter product,
but once you see that
there's a [INAUDIBLE],
your content is being pressured.
Then that's where you
can activate that.
Cost-wise, it's not expensive.
What you get it's
about $80 per months
per 1 gigabyte instances.
MARTIN GORNER: All right,
let's get back to this list.
So next, are DataStore writes.
Those you told me are even
more expensive and even slower.
JEROME MOUTON: Mm-hm.
MARTIN GORNER: So again, what
can you do to help there?
JEROME MOUTON: So the one
thing you need to keep in mind
is every time you process
an entity in the DataStore,
you not only process every
attribute of this entity,
like every field,
but you also ask
App Engine to create an index
for each of these attributes.
Like, typically,
you have a user.
You have the name of the
person, the email address, maybe
a phone number.
Processing that will not have
three write, but will have six
writes for each index, as well.
On top of that, if you
need help with the indexes,
like if you need to be able
to do queries to find people
on phone number on email
address-- I'm not sure
why you do that, but-- you
have to define an initial index
in your object definition.
That would be also on write
another write permission.
MARTIN GORNER: So there is
a write amplification effect
that when you write one entity,
every property in that entity
that is indexed, that
uses an additional write.
And also, every
pair of properties
that is indexed in a
composite index, that
also produces an
additional write.
JEROME MOUTON: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: All
right, so you have
to be very careful with that.
JEROME MOUTON: You
have to be careful.
Keep it in mind.
And you have a way through some
properties, your definition
of object to tell
App Engine, please,
do no create an index
for this attribute.
For example, the
name of the person
may not be something
you search on.
So you just say, make this
attribute not indexed.
And that way you can
save significantly
on the number of
write operations.
MARTIN GORNER: But
that will prevent you
from ever querying
by that property.
JEROME MOUTON: Yes, that's
correct, Martin, yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: All right,
but that's what you--
JEROME MOUTON: It's a trade off,
yeah. [? Otherwise, ?] yeah,
it's like cost
versus flexibility.
MARTIN GORNER: And so the
last item on this list
here is bandwidth.
So it doesn't seem to be that
significant in your case,
but you told me that you
optimized it quite well.
What did you do to
achieve this low number?
JEROME MOUTON: Similar
things here, as well.
On App Engine, for
Java, for example,
you are hosted on a
separated container.
So you have complete access
to the HTTP serving headers.
There are headers specific
for caching instruction,
telling the browser
to keep your content
for a certain amount of time.
So by playing with these
cache control headers,
you can leverage there's
a reduction of hit
on your application,
telling the browser
to reuse what they
have, so, yes.
MARTIN GORNER: Right.
And also, well, of
course, that's the basics.
But you should be
careful of the resources
that you use, images,
JavaScript resources, and so
on-- the static resources.
JEROME MOUTON: Right.
Something else I can
mention here as well,
not applicable for
everybody, but since we
are using Java for our back-end,
our team is better with Java.
And we also use Java to
create our Java Scripts
with a GWT framework.
So by doing that, it
offer a lot of flexibility
for testing everything, but
also rely on the GWT compiler
to create highly
optimized JavaScript
code for each target.
So we won't serve the same
JavaScript to a Firefox user
or to Chrome user, which
means we serve the smallest
possible amount of data
to each of our customers.
MARTIN GORNER: All
right, thank you, Jerome.
And there is one more point that
I would like you to touch upon.
It's you told me
that you have started
using App Engine before
it even had a name.
Can you tell us a
bit more about that?
JEROME MOUTON: Yeah, back I
think it was very early 2008,
I was contracting for
Google for some gadget ads
project, building these very
smart ads which show content,
contextual to what the person
search, where they are located.
And as part of doing
this contracting,
I had early access
to the platform.
I thought only at the
time, very limited to all
the functionalities,
but it allowed
me to see the value of having
a system that scales by itself.
As you can imagine,
these ad campaigns
spike very quickly when the
ad companies launch, and then
scale down quickly,
as well, when
the ad companies turn down.
So the value proposition of
App Engine, to go to scale
and just pay for what you use,
it's huge in this situation.
MARTIN GORNER: And so
that was back in 2000 and?
JEROME MOUTON: And
eight, early 2008.
MARTIN GORNER: 2008, all right.
So you have been an App
Engine expert since 2008?
JEROME MOUTON: Yeah. [LAUGHS]
MARTIN GORNER:
That's impressive.
JEROME MOUTON:
Thank you, Martin.
The thing is, when we decided
to launch SnapEngage in 2009,
so one [INAUDIBLE] year
later, we were already
convinced that the
platform was what
we wanted to do
with a small team
to have the capacity
to grow quickly.
Let me mention
something else here,
since we have a bit more time.
Typically, when you
host application
on an instance-based
platform, and you
have to kind of provision
your instances yourself,
you will grow by chunk.
Where if you see your
traffic is growing,
you will have to get a
new cluster of instances
because of this traffic.
Scaling down is
difficult at night
when the traffic goes down.
You typically don't
turn off instances
because it's a lot
of work to do that.
With App Engine, your
growth would be linear
because you pay
for what you use.
The platform will add
instances when needed.
When the traffic
slows down at night,
they will take down instances.
And you won't be charged.
So it's a huge difference
in the bottom line
compared to traditional hosting.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
Thank you very much, Jerome.
Thank you for being with us
here at "Root Access Berlin."
And we'll be seeing you in the
next episode of "Root Access
Berlin."
Thank you.
JEROME MOUTON:
Thank you, Martin.
Thank you for having me.